bonjour bienvenue sur diagonale tb leçon
spéciale
ouverture aujourd'hui on va voir une
ouverture très connu l'abbé nous lie
avec jean baptiste mulon beaux jours
jean baptiste par jean-stéphane dans
tout le monde
l'abbé l'onil appel à une ouverture de
fous furieux
elle renouvelle ce fou furieux qu'il
peut être une ouverture que sur laquelle
on transpose beaucoup dans plusieurs
variantes
disons que ça des points communs avec
avec une cousine de la bella nicky et
l'estonienne savait pas en commun il ya
beaucoup de variantes qui sont vraiment
très proches et en particulier la vendée
quatre pions
qui est une ouverture communal à benoni
et à lester indienne et
donc l'idée de l'idée de la baie de nice
et de donner comme dans l'estrie yens 1
force entre blancs et de pouvoir
l'attaquer après par un jeu de flan et
avec le risque de se faire complètement
enfoncé au sens à cause de grandes
concessions trop grande alors on voit ça
tout de suite
la benoni qui vient de rentrer dans le
répertoire de notre numéro un français
etienne bacrot kaka transféré son style
un petit peu en ce moment qu'ils ont des
voitures très tranchante qui s'adapte
qui s'adapte au plus haut niveau
voilà qui se rend compte que son style
peut-être un peu trop prudent des débuts
suffisant pour gagner des propriétés de
caïds et une partie se joue fil du
rasoir tout ça alors des quatre califes
6 c 4 6 1 alors pour l'instant
ça pourrait ressembler à une autre
couverture qui s'appelle l'animent zoo
indienne oui par exemple sur les coûts
cavaliers ces trois-là nîmes ou indienne
qui fera l'objet d'une c3 c'est le coup
c'est le coucou m'avoir qui fera l'objet
d'une leçon bien sûr se jouer tous les
cas c'est le couffo b4 voilà donc l'idée
que critiquent son spécial sur le nîmes
jour elle le fonds spécial c'est autre
chose
voilà et là on a une autre idée on veut
jouer 5 6 5
voilà voilà donc dans les stalles
viennent quand les noirs jouent 6,5 on
va retrouver le même type de mariage
voilà on va voir des séries là on bon
coup pour les glandes situées des séries
on veut pas laisser le pion décès changé
avec le pion c'est donc on prend nos
thèses au centre le prends des cinq
s'éprend des 5es des six
voilà donc là on voit que les blancs
vont avoir un avantage centrale
considérable avec le pion au caté les
pions des 5
cela dit les noirs ont des lignes
ouvertes quand même sur ce centre donc
il ya une belle colonnes voilà ce que
j'admire la colonne et puis il ya les
noirs pourvoi le voir ressortir le fou
ou elf 8h05 eto'o donc une très belle
diagonale aussi c'est un jeu de pièces
la mezzanine
alors qu un relief 3 voilà donc là il ya
plusieurs suites alors
on joue toujours cavalier f3 sauf dans
deux variantes particulière aux qu'on va
voir d'abord oui c'est la vente des
quatre pions alors sur décision va bref
à cause de leur handicap turquie est une
version très compliqué on va voir en
quoi ça consiste
pourquoi de 4 on appelle voir des quatre
pions parce que dans l'east indienne il
ya encore le pur en c4 et le pion à eux
cette voie là et on va jouer le l'autre
pions après j'ai si souvent joué
d'autres pions ici en f4 jeunesse quatre
machines qui avait un quatrième qui en
lice il imagine un pur là et que les
normes pas encore joué aussi celle qui
voit là sinon en fait on peut dire que
ce qu'ils racontent à quel point il
n'avait qu'à le croire mais on pourra
retrouver là quatre pions vous imaginez
cette indienne comme ça on a le
quatrième pion ici est en fait tout
autant les noirs jouent par exemple ces
scènes et les blancs jouent des 5 et les
voir vous aussi c'est on échange on joue
aussi sa baignoire en échange le centre
et on revient de cette position après
foulée 7 alors le coût principal c'est
fou mais cinq échecs poulets s'est
couchée qui permet aux blancs de
développer une pièce tout en gagnant un
tempo entre guillemets en faisant échec
alors sachant que sur sur fou 17 et bien
les noirs sont pas tellement satisfait
finalement d'échanger des pièces puisque
ils ont ils ont besoin de toutes leurs
pièces pour essayer de vaincre le centre
blanc et donc quitte à proposer un
échange de pièces on préfère jouer un
cavalier puisque ça les bons coups 17
les garde-fous sépare très intéressant
sur son fou 17 les blancs de prendre et
on essaie tout simplement oui ou alors
je jouerai au simple parce que là on a
lancé oui c'est un cas de prises en
bessin comprend d'abord le quatrième six
et on est une pièce exactement donc
c'est ça le problème de cette variante
c'est pour ça que sur foot b5 et bien
finalement les les noirs sont quasiment
obligée de faire cavalier f17 lieu de
fou 17 et pas et pas l'autre
pas celui pour la reille bas parce que
pour la même raison pour exactement les
mêmes raisons à cause de ça inc
voilà la nouvelle cavaliers vous voyez
que là c'est le cas au direct un oil
cavaliers il n'y a pas de casse
cavaliers s'il vient par exemple on
avait cinq sur la rue aux six mois je
vais aussi sont annoncés ici perdu on
avait une pièce vous voyez que surfe
l'ouest cinq échecs faut pas se tromper
un façon payant il faut faire attention
on est obligé de jouer cavalier f17
voilà donc il faut jouer le seul coup ci
ça déjà attention a laissé une ouverture
que c'est une ouverture de et la a4
d'acrobates 1-3-4 curieux alors à quatre
c'est tout à fait logique en fait ça a
l'air un peu bidon aux agents de l'aide
mais c'est à dire que l'on veut pas que
les noirs se servent de notre fougue et
5 pour jouer dans la foulée à 6 et
bétail afab et 5
donc là sur a6 on bouge le fou et b
celle qui paraît presque impossible
c'est pour prévenir 5 ou prophylactiques
voilà assez important
sylvain joué par exemple fort bien une
erreur par exemple en jouant cavalier 3
on en profiterait pour faire à 6
évidemment si en échange le fondant
cavaliers c'est une bonne affaire pour
les noirs plutôt est ce qu'une position
quand même quasi ouvert à ça va s'ouvrir
voilà très vite avec des paires de fou
c'est intéressant ici le plan des blancs
c'est d'ouvrir à 14,56 peuvent plus le
faire ils ont une plante 5 comme un fou
reviennent tout simplement des scènes
maintenant les voilà les blés noirs ont
déjà une forte d'initiatives à la lhdaa
voilà donc là la partie commence une
bonne base pour les noirs les secoue à 4
qui paraît illogique dans les principes
dans les faits finalement cette fois
encore tout à fait logique
un bon petit rock petit rock kalyev tron
qu'elle est très vite on va faire pire
que nos six cavaliers à 6 très musicaux
si on profite de la case b4 affaibli par
le pion à 4 bien sûr c'est un cavani qui
va faire pression sur la purge des 5 1
le joueur au tennis et ça on n'a pas
peur des changes et les pions ici parce
qu'on aurait eu certes des pions doubler
mon a donné quand même la paire de fou
et en plus la colonne b et la case b4
est toujours faible voilà donc je ne
sente pas grand chose ils sont fous à la
mi-mai mieux un pion de moins on s'en
foutrait quoi ce serait comme une
aubaine complètement développé des
montants faudrait peut-être puisque on
voudrait la casa 6 pour le faux ou
améliorer sa notation alors qu'elle
venait à 6 ok donc petit rock qu'on n'a
pas peur et la qualité car voilà l'idée
évidemment c'est cette case b4 qui n'ont
pas venir ans et 7 qui était possible
aussi mais qui était plus passif on dit
en mai quatre belles cases le clavier
quand même et actif quand on est casés
videmment il peut pas déloger ce
cavalier donc il est bien
h3 ouais je prends donc ça c'est pour
pourquoi pas pousser g15 ouais c'est
surtout aussi empêché empêcher un fou de
devenir bien sûr parce qu'on veut garder
un oeil sur la casse des quatre puisque
windows 7 qui aimerait bien venir là
aussi et fait donc ici à six salles
seller comme on va chasser ce fou quand
même fils ziad et la f5 et là c'est
l'heure pour fc chooz classique
alors on met la ville du fait que les
noirs contrôle très bien la casse de
samedi contrôler la case au sol tout cas
je veux c est qu ils contrôlent la case
de 5 c'est vrai
en fait on se désolidariser
désolidariser les pions ont aidé et donc
on comprend dans le rôle du cavalier
bekkat mais là où ses forces et que les
noirs contrôle très bien à gaza 5 mais
finalement le seul point intéressant
pour les blancs si je joue cinq ans s
est joué 5 parce que sur un autre coup
comme me prend f5 par exemple savourer
tout simplement sans doute reprend le
prendre parce que ça fait une belle case
je prends pas d'ombré on ferait une
belle s'offrait une belle case de
soutien pour la caisse de cadres eux
aussi bien sur le plan soutient la case
de 4 on peut remettre le cavaliere f6
après on a une soutiennent que le cas de
gain on peut mettre une tour 1,8
on pourra mettre un cavalier le 4 on est
on est pas mal et puis on a toujours ce
qu'elle baisse 4 qui a un oeil sur des
saints qui ça peut s'avérer fatale
depuis le début on dit que les blancs
doivent percuté au centre et là ils ont
plus cette percussion scellés et les
noirs qui gigotait maintenant je suis
tellement en hausse de 15,6 qui est
faible sinon oui oui c'est une
possibilité mais ce n'est pas dramatique
mais voilà en tout cas voilà où voilà où
ça mène alors qu'on pourrait être le
coup eux cinq peut-être juste avant
alors f5 là maintenant ici peu senghor
regarder un petit peu le bazar ça peut
être dans cette bd évidemment prendre
alors ya près de prendre 5 mais là on
attaque à la découverte avec des six je
décide quand même on prend pas en compte
par le segment il c'est très important
de se libérer d'abord la casse des 5 et
6 seront ensuite voilà et là cavalier
collège et 5 g 5 voilà c'est ça l'idée
donc double menace à la fois aux six
hommes par des belle triplette en fait
on pourra choisir se comprendre et aussi
s est vrai avec une fourchette
protégé par le fou c4 voilà un gros
souci ce case blanche
voilà voilà tout simplement donc l'idée
après je me rappelle très bien de ce que
dit la théorie mais je crois qu'on se
laisse prendre la qualité en fait et on
a une grosse activité avec les pions
aussi donc vous voyez que ces ouvertures
temps du temps du vrai mais il ya une
autre possibilité intéressante peut-être
c'est de jouer cavalier mais vite un peu
étonnant dans ce cas liés à la maison en
fait on va perdre nos qualités mais ce
cavalier venir en c6 est appréhendé
quatre et en asie
oui voudraient forte légère et l'option
des six est un peu coupés du reste du
reste du monde
donc finalement ça fera deux pions
peut-être pour la qualité des pièces
très bien placé pour peindre foucras la
voilà et maintenant on peut jouer ou 4
aussi n'aura laon concerne le bureau kde
sûr parce que si on va pas évidemment de
prendre f4 que ça fait ressortir le fou
c'est elle qui protégerait des 6 1
jouant eux quatre regarder voilà
n'empêche le phocéen avec le mit
mauvaise pièce et puis on se donne un
très beau soutien sur la case d3
regardez le cavalier et regardez
regardez ce superbe kazan des trois
voies non ça fait plaisir c'est vrai que
là on a donné une qualité mais on a des
pions un pur ont pour l'instant
peut-être l'option des six plus tard et
puis une belle activité de pièces
saintot on a un jeu facile même contre
la qualité on a quand même un pion passé
et le protéger en plus donc voilà donc
la variante des quatre pions valente
très très tendue si on joue pour le gain
avec les noirs on est plutôt content de
jouer donc
donc si c'était sur e4 direct voilà donc
peut-être pas les g3 maintenant une
autre variante alors on va voir ça voilà
j'ai 3 g iii donc une variante un peu
plus tranquille finirait g63 voilà en
fait on prend pas de décision immédiate
avec le pion à eux pour pas donner trop
de cible au noir voilà donc on protège
le plan des 5,1 directement aux menaces
de le protéger à tout moment d'un grand
cavalier
voilà car les bd c'est donc maintenant
voilà on peut sortir tranquillement à 4
toujours le même la même idée à 6,6 et
on joue à quatre maintenant regarder ce
que si on l'avait joué trop tôt
peut-être lé nounours revenir à 6 et b4
donc là maintenant qu'il ait joué en 17
on peut jouer à quatre alors plus
difficile d'ailleurs les 4000 ans
importante dans ce cas et d2 alors
classique dans ce type de structure et
le cavalier venir ou en ses cartes mais
en même temps je libère la force du fou
au g2 qui protège très bien et en
dépenser 4 je tape un petit peu sur le
pion des six mais aussi pourquoi pas sur
la case b6 les pièces en ville on sait
jamais ça empêche la dame noire de
partir et on peut souvent joué avec le
calice et qu'à travers une conjonction
avec le coup à 5
voilà pour verrouiller totalement la
case 2006 voilà ce genre d'idées alors
cavaliers hc voilà du coup et là on en
profite ce cas elle 5-2 pour venir au
centre
regardez l'idc j'attaque des 6 et hop le
deuxième cavalier va pouvoir attaquer
une deuxième fois des voiliers que les
blancs sont pas livrés au niveau des
pions donc c'est plutôt un jeu de pièces
ici de parts et d'autres
on essaie de de valoriser chacun son
côté ses pièces développement des noirs
on veut dire proposer l'échangé de
cavaliers
dire que d'un problème hélas crise
éclate alors dit qu'on me l'ait bien s
cavale il est bien allé c'est vraiment
une car il est superbe on va voir
d'ailleurs on va voir après être tombé à
8 on a envie de jouer v5 les blancs vont
jouer cavalier besikats les v6 madame
des 8 à 5,18 maintenant assez inquiets
voire des voix l'a regardée comme une
boule à ce qu'il dit mais le coût à
saint-philibert stéphane castry casque
p5 les blancs dont je vais fou d'essai
voilà voilà est le même ils ont une très
belle case pour leur fougue maintenant
voilà et ce cavalier un b6 c'est vrai il
a complètement verrouillé la dame voilée
on a l'impression que les gars se sont
bien remis quand même tout à fait voilà
donc chacun a ses atouts c'est comme si
la toux ou v5 évidemment on en profite
de ce petit coup parce que sur dame
prend évidemment car elle y prend fou
avec fourchette avec fourchette
voilà donc là il faut jouer on en
profite un coup comme m6 mais on aime
bien que forcément vous ce genre de
coups puisque un fou qui bouchent le fou
j'ai cet arrêt donc on joue tous des
deux
non non on peut il ya plus vous prendrez
de 5,95 leurs attaques si on revenait
angers sans un peignoir j'aurais
cavaliers cette fois ci tournait un
voile à fo bessin fou desseigne voilà
avec une bonne partie pour les noirs
voilà une partie partie au chacun chacun
a des chances mais les et noir ont une
position en qui peut pas être mauvaise
passe que mémoire on est très bonne
pièce
le projet sera obligé deux pour un jean
de bennani je pense que c'est aussi une
bonne nouvelle une bien meilleure que
les grandes lignes un jeu un peu trop
tranquille où les noirs s'en sont très
bien donc on va regarder maintenant la
grande variante dérange vraiment car il
y avait 3 g 6e 80 où j'essaie alors là
des coûts soient faux de soi h3 qui
retrouve également beaucoup dans la
théorie pour éviter que le fou c'est 8
vient de s'échanger contre le cavaliere
3 dont on a besoin pour pousser eux cinq
plus tard
donc on regarde d'abord peut-être locaux
font eux deux ont peur des vous fout de
l'eau ici bon à la fois et deux fois 2
petit vent les pirogues petit rock tour
on proteste pression sur le pion aux
quatre donc calé des deux classiques
elle a toujours la même idée
et on défend ici on jouera peut-être
tous fous des trois peut-être que c'est
pas plus tard ou peut-être quatre où est
roi ouais aussi cavaillé à 6 f3c 7 à 4
maintenant à quatre on va toujours
pareil on jouera quatre on protège notre
corps notre futur car il s'écarte voilà
on lui on lui assure sa population sa
case des six cas et c'est 4 x 6 voilà le
fou qui évidemment qu'il n'y a aucune
case ici hors dé tout est prêt on est
comme cette chaîne de pions bouffe tout
tout tout les 4 ans et militaire élevé
un endroit où se poster à là dessus
c'est h six questions de fond la food &
2 ça fait ça fait deux fois qu'on voit
que fut ce développement des deux en
fait on n'a pas peur environ on évite
souvent le droit parce qu'il fait rien
d'autre
il tape sur du vide et puis souvent
aussi à weesp aidant il a des soucis
avec la dans la ligne de mire la danse
est pas très restreint à la fin on peut
prendre on peut sacrifier le dessin qui
parfois parce que le foot roi se
retrouve en vérité il faut te faire
attention à ça vous prend vous prend à
six voies là bas on a envie de contrôler
la case bessac important d un plancher
on va empêcher un fou b5 et poussé 6
avec un peu pénible oui ce serait
une épine dans leur position c'est pas
très agréable dans me2 fait exact
compression sur le cul rend ainsi ce
qu'avait 17 alors qu'alizé c'est
toujours intéressant à la fois on peut
envisager 25
et puis il ya quand même tout entier
salah et sa lumière le fou ça libère
aussi le fou 17 et parfois on va aussi
russell pour parfois on veut tenter les
blancs de jouer le même f4 et c'est
souvent intéressant aussi h15
donc là on profite du vis-à-vis tour
dames tour à 20 on n'est qu'à aller aux
cinq attaques
le fou ces quatre fous à deux essais
leur maintenant pour jouer mais c'est un
cas oui on profite que la torah vite va
exercer une action serrure sur le foie
de regarder la variante quand on va le
regarder un petit peu si les blancs
prennent ça va pas être prises
maintenant imaginez que cavalier prend
des scènes tout simplement impossible à
coude tout prendre voilà donc le projet
sap n'est pas prenable dont on le fait
au bon moment
donc ne permet b5 fou mais attention
maintenant bessin qui est attaquée ils
ne m'ont donc d'amd cette voie là très
bien lille et tours protège des cercles
parfaits garde la souplesse ici voilà
donc on peut toujours jouer soit c4
sauver 4 ça peut être intéressant les
deux avec 2 1 par exemple ici si on
prend qui comprend qu'à va les prendre
mais on est déjà desservie qu'attention
problème ouais c'est la frontière près
du pont lecavalier cinq étages qu'à la
fin de la partie
donc voilà certes pas tellement envie de
reprendre du pillon surprendre évident
ce qualité nord voilà on faisait les
plus brefs pour déloger le cavalier seul
donc là on va sacrifier sacrifie le pion
des scènes grand nombre sacrifient l'une
des 50 cl tac et après f 4k et ckd
phocéen pour déloger les blancs
sacrifier mais on voit que toutes leurs
pièces sont quand même très bien placé
et elle n'oubliera une belle attaque en
perspective sur le roi noir c'est une
position qui fait penser à des parties
de kasparov contre karpov saint à
l'espagnol dans l'espagnol souvent les
deux fous placé là et à la fin c'est lui
qui m'a presque une position de
l'espagnol
vous noterez ici que là quand même il ya
une petite faiblesse il notamment g6 y
signer le footballeur il lorgne sur
cette faiblesse dès que le cavalier à
bouger que la dame peut très vite venir
en g3 par exemple pour attaquer cette
faiblesse
et en plus si si regardez peut y avoir
une diagonale ici avec le roi qui est
derrière et puis deux belles pièces
qu'on est moyen gober au passage ça peut
aller vite si les noirs prennent ici par
exemple pour x 2 et un gros souci voilà
il faut faire très attention aux
stations intéressante
d'ailleurs c'est ce que font apparemment
l'énoncé de participants n'ont peut-être
pas regarder la suite parce que c'est
les dames chez trois déjà voilà commence
à attaquer g6 et pour aussi se défendre
dans le détroit
là on commence à voir la dame des trois
là pouf pouf pouf tout est attaqué par
des tacles et deux dames en plus il ya
une batterie fouda main qui peut lorgner
ici f5 peut être à l'heure à l'ordre du
jour ça va être à l'ordre du jour tu
veux continuer la partie oui qu'elle
allait céder 6 5 live sync saillie bon
là on voit que ça y est c'est délicat
dédicace est pas finie mais ça finit
mais en fait ça fait peur moi je mange
pas je vous laisse avec les noirs parce
qu'alors la recette a fait ça fait quand
même très peur après j'y prends avec
cinq tours prime time la menace
imminente et tout reprendre cavaliers tu
auras 8 1 40 au programme animé sur ça
fait peur ces quatre d'âme des uns sont
calés prend des scènes tout simplement
d'apprendre les cinq une tourte couler
ici d'offrir toujours énorme
on croit qu'il peut a l'air voilà c'est
une partie de bandes velits face à un
grand grand joueur jusqu'à sa date aux
palois de la face c'est pas ça c'est pas
celle là dans sa séquence qui ça oui
enfin une partie très intéressante voilà
voilà le genre de parti sorti qu'au nord
ont gagné d'ailleurs n'en finit par
gagner il faut n'est pas gagné vous
voyez c'est pas simple après que dans le
bessin par exemple qu'on peut montrer
pour
voilà rassurés peut-être que ceux qui
préféraient et ben voilà il ya quand
même cinq pions un pour les noirs deux
pièces contre contre la tour et de pions
donc c'est passé pas simple après
peut-être les blancs ne pas jouer les
meilleurs coups mais c'est vrai quand
même que ça fait peur à jouer et qu'il
faut avoir les nerfs solides du côté
défensif ici pour quand même pour vous
retenir la leçon pour jouer une mélodie
faut avoir les nerfs solides
or les nerfs solides pour avoir envie de
gagner et avoir les nerfs solides
donc on va regarder la partie avec h3
peut-être alors où en étions-nous
huitième coup ici voilà on avait vu ça
c'est sûr de fouet aux deux tirages 3way
petit rock on est comme si riche des
trois fous des trois donc la classique
un souvent le fou vient aussi en d3 pour
protéger le petit local est lente la b5
c'est le coût théorique au fit très bon
coup puisque le roi est encore en eux un
regard des cons on invite une des
défenses du pian 2 4 allait prendre le
pion de beyssac et s'ils n'en veulent
pas le bas tant mieux pour nous on aura
déjà bien bien avancé on va le jouer
gallas sur rien un souci orné l'idée
c'est que quand le roi est au centre on
va pouvoir sacrifier ans le 4 avec tours
vite derrière un il a posté il ya deux
pièces qui défend mais s'il ya une pièce
qui défend apprend joué cinq étoiles un
très vite ça saute donc on va regarder
d'abord fou prend messin premier 5 par
exemple ici regardez donc cavale et
provoque à l'épreuve
il faut prendre il n'y a pas le choix
trop et là regardez ouf même dame à 5
ouais et oui l'idée c'est que même si le
coup car alice et 3 est envisageable
sam un prélat français il ya vous prend
et on récupère le fourbe et celle en
empêchant le petit rock et on pourra
jouer fois ci voilà le petit rock sera
jamais possible
voilà la colonne est toujours ouverte
donc c'est un peu la catastrophe qu'il
faut jouer des coups comme câble est là
et on fait quand même d'un pro mais
c'est oui parce que lorsqu un pion des
6es en l'air c'est pour ça parce qu'on
prend confiance
c'est un massif par des dames assises
pourquoi regarder toujours l'idée 1
ça s'est mal aime parce qu'on attaque le
quart allégations mais surtout regarder
on garde l'oeil sur la case fr qu'est-ce
qui va venir la regarder un petit tour
un petit tour à 8 très vite sans doute
surtout en des buts pour attaquer le
cavalier voilà donc ici car les ckd
logique on essaie de boucher la colonne
tour des huit fois f4 pour protéger
peuvent être protégées vous voyez que
cet équilibre est fragile et noir vont
à jouer car l'idée cette petit rock et
cavaliers b6 mais la maintenance ou va
se simplifier gares aux quais noirs
contre contre kharkov martine jolit
tahir a gagné d'ailleurs aussi savent
allier prends je vais prendre pour
apprendre tomber voilà mon année comme
la judith joue très bien elle va baisser
grâce à l'option des 6 rapp rendre fou
et fuit à prendre ce pur en force en
force elle va le bel val est carrément
le chercher voilà ça y est terminée
voilà et la grèce position avec la dame
qu'entre les deux tours d'un comprise de
tous était pas forcément gagnant je
pense que les quatre prévenus
oui sur l'avenir d'un enfant oisif rda
gaza précision et essayer de gagner
lui-même sans doute mais la position des
n'est pas mauvaise pour les mort
elle-même plutôt bonne mais pas mauvais
c'est difficile pour les blancs
évidemment les deux tours génération
sont supérieurs à la vente les blancs
n'est pas de faiblesse voilà faut pas
que ces deux faiblesses là il y en a pas
un épais les pions a et b sont
considérées comme faibles puisque la
tourbe et un peu pas trop partir pas
partir donc si je pouvais partir ça veut
dire qu'il ya pas trop de jeu voilà faut
jouer quand même précis annonce alors ça
c'était la première prise sur foot pro b
5 et maintenant quelle qui marquait les
premiers singles alors là vous allez
voir qu'il faut c'est la même idée il
faut déjà regarder plus attentivement
ses taux à 8 dont attac donc là l'idée
c'est qu'une vidéo on attaque tout à
fait donc ici otage avec l'autre
cavaliers ont même les provoquer quand
même vous prendre puisqu'il ya le fameux
je pense qu'avec scène tout de suite
mais non x 6 d'abord fois ci serait
alors on reste évidemment toujours
pareil avec l'idée il ya voilà faire un
jeu extrêmement violent donc là c'est la
partie de topalov contre vendredi c'est
vrai que f5 on se regarde en réserve on
va le placer au ont donné on a une pièce
de moins fort et bien là
récupérer pour l'instant on active tout
ce qu'on peut activer à 4 mrd russsie
balaie le thème s'arrête au cloud à
damas cinq cette partie là si rock voire
d y aura il vous prend et on peut pas
reprendre
on va là à cause d'un prend un tour
voilà donc d'un médecin qui m'a l'air à
cause de ça donc ici cavalli prend des
six on n'a pas peur à chaque fois
demandé à chaque fois sacrifie et là où
est très joli coup de taux pas le voir
l'addition car les 17 ilan pappe poteau
pour le tout pour le développement il va
donner la qualité et puis là surtout là
ça y est on regardait avec un fou pousse
t racisme on pourra jamais rauque et là
tout à fait donc là topalov il adore ça
lui a baissé de l'acquis leroy mc2 f5
seller comme prévu qu'elle prend à tour
cran quand il prend 1,8
une tour d' au moins pour l'instant mais
on voit qu'on va récupérer avons au
moins une pièce donc voir une qualité de
moi énormément d'activité et surtout il
voilà c'est tout voilà toutes les pièces
active l'europe qui veut par ok donc
saddam impressionnant comme ça donnait
une tour mais en carélie qui a tant que
ça de venir à 1 50 et 3 après une fois
que le fousseret sortie il va il ya une
super 15 en d3 aussi donc ça fait peur
quand même
roi des huns donc il comprend le 4 et a
déjà sabré c'est ça vous regarde et le
fou g7 qui tape le fois ci ce qui
empêche toute façon l'europe qui
salissent et fini puisqu'il a bougé le
cavalier qui attend plus ça que ça
devenir soit en b 6 pour attaquer de
loin mêlé à la fête 4 soit sévère 5 4 au
5 allée des trois menaçant d ici une
fourchette enfin bon c'est horrible ça
fait peur voilà donc pour accroître il y
avait aussi la menace du pion eux qui
allaient en trois peut-être c4 voilà
donc qui va se libérer des cases à 4 c 5
peut-être 3 et en prendre des symboles à
s'allier à des cas la position est belle
malgré malgré la la
la qualité c'est une petite qualité on a
le même nombre de pièces c'est vraiment
une position extraordinaire on va on va
dérouler cette partie que comme très
belle touche f8 tout prendre 4 on ne
change pas ici trois fuites f3 protège
qu'elle et ses cinq cavaliers arrive
comme prévu les autorités pour éviter
les chausse des to attack la tour donc
là où va la tour accessoirement les
nôtres 7 6 6 tout prend 1,7 quand même
et ça fait quand même des pions qui sont
bouffés c'est l'heure pour ces trois
attaques évidemment le cavalier d2 il
faut prendre alors il prend pas en
sicile avait pris 6 e faisable a priori
c'était une autre une autre possibilité
on va attendre on peut jouer fous ces
quatre avec la menace four b3 la dame
cette trêve c'est très joli s'attaquer
fiche de dégagement ces mois-ci série
fils de dégagement célébré pour la
classe c est pour ça qu il prend le pur
le pion à 6 voilà bien qu intermédiaire
malheureusement donc ça a été violent
prend des deux mois là et là regardez
c'est déjà fini puisque on attaque à la
fois la tour et le phocéen
on voit pas trop ce que peuvent faire
les noirs ils sacrifient ici la tour
mais bon c'est en désespoir de cause et
ça change rien parce qu'on prend c'est
avec échec échec
et après on va penser à tout simplement
tout reprendre tour il ya une pièce de
plus contre trois pions mais là le roi
non roi blanc est toujours tellement
faible que voilà qui a fait la meilleure
option mais avec effectivement une
grosse grosse attaque on s'attaque qui
continue et qui va qui va pas s'arrêter
batraville partie encore un voilà donc
avec les blancs si vous aimez le combat
vous avez un
vous avez la possibilité de jouer soit
avec la 4 pions soit soit ce type de
variantes aussi va qui perd là on n'a
pas envie de se faire mater comme ça
price a relaté comme ça on peut jouer
des warrants tendue en relevant le défi
quand même voilà n'est pas obligé de
perdre la partie n'a pas toujours été
perdante pour enlever lice oui on a
donné plutôt une idée du style qu'il
faut avoir avec les noirs on n'a pas dit
que c'était gagnant de bout en bout pour
les noirs si on veut jouer plus près
d'un montant des ventes avec g3 un peu
plus tranquille
un cavalier f34 est fou et 200 une
vingtaine but du mc très noir en tout
cas vous voyez que vous voulez provoquer
un peu le combat c'est une variante très
intéressante
ouais il faut prendre on y réfléchit je
pense que je vais réfléchir au sens
raconte moi et je serai réfléchir et
c'est intéressant sans que les indiennes
vin va faire une petite pause peut-être
peut-être peut-être y avoir un
entraînement mais donner bientôt
regarder on va garder ça en réservant
ses jets on sait jamais alors voilà donc
ce n'est pas libre et je ne livre pas
les informations déjà qu'en plus on est
on est on n'est pas tout seul
alors donc merci d'avoir suivi cette
émission avec nous dès qu'on a été une
leçon spéciale benoni puis je vous donne
rendez vous pour notre ouverture
spéciale avec jean baptiste merci au
revoir au revoir